never feel guilty for the work others
have to do to win in life
and I read this at 30 years old 29 30
years old I got a hold of this book
that's very hard to get a hold of it he
wrote a couple books one is called
pushing up people another one is called
uh all you can do is all you can do but
all you can do is enough but this book
is not a CL you can't buy it in
bookstore so I got a hold of it
and it said never feel guilty like never
feel guilty
never feel guilty wow hey that guy's got
to pay the price as well if he says he's
got this big dream he's got to pay the
price so never feel guilty
pbd yes you are officially the first
guest in my new studio and I'm very
happy to have you here my friend well
first of all congratulations place looks
amazing and thanks for having me man I
mean you when when Sam said Pat's
schedule correct because we're leaving
in New York tomorrow yeah can we make
this I said it's Dave no question about
it we got to figure it out so we got
down here to uh be here with you there
were several reasons I wanted to do this
mostly because I knew you were dressed
to the nines to show up here and that
first guest has to dress right but that
is part of the pbd operation right like
looking good dressing right taking care
of yourself it's part of the kind of
whole thing that has given you success I
would say so I think you know when when
you got to know this is not what I was
used to growing up I don't think I've
ever worn a suit as a kid maybe I went
to a wedding one time and we wore a suit
but you go to the military you come out
I'm the baggy pants guy size 48 jeans
with Dickies and I've seen some of the
old pictures yeah you do some of those
old Throwbacks that's that's some of my
stuff and then I go to the Army I get
out in the Army I start wearing videos
and I started falling in love with
ironing my clothes with starch from PX
and Shining my boots for a couple hours
I love doing that and then when I got
out and started working in business and
one of my guys at Morgan Stanley
Deanwood said you got to get a nice suit
and then I put it on I said I kind of
like this and then you know the rest is
obviously history when did uh well first
off let's do a little yes cheers man
cheers congrats on this thank you thank
you and everything well everything that
we're going to talk about is sort of a I
would say a congrats to both of us
because we both moved our lives and
operations yes to this free state and it
has pretty much worked since then I
agree so I agree to that
I should know by the way you're you're
doing the whiskey you're a whiskey guy
you're doing to what you're doing the
tequila I'm a tequila okay I try to
finish all the tequila in the world
didn't work so I gave it back and I
moved to Whiskey I want to get you on
tequila can I tell you that the bottle I
think Connor can we get a shot of the
bottle behind me that's the most
expensive bottle I've ever bought in my
life no joke 550 bucks get out of here a
bottle of tequila but I was like you
know what new studio things are going
all right for you I'm sitting down with
pbd I've had my eye on that bottle for a
long time and I went out and bought it
yesterday and I was like we're gonna do
it well listen I mean it matches your
one bedroom condo you live in here yeah
can you believe I sleep in this room
I love how my my Purdue right before we
start my producer Phoenix says to you
hey Patrick what what kind of watch is
that without flinching going
no but obviously your house is a
beautiful house what you got here
congrats to your success on what you've
done going from where you were at I love
you I'm asking you what are these VHS
that you know from stand up to now being
one of the most powerful voices out
there man it's great to see you you know
I was well that's truly that's why I
wanted to have you in for this first
show because your dedication to success
and and trying to replicate that for
other people I mean those days when I
was doing that I was broke I mean broke
I didn't have 50 bucks I was borrowing
change to get a cup of coffee at Zabar's
on the upper west side so I could do a
little stand up at night to pray for the
dream I had a buddy uh this is totally
true I had a buddy who worked in food
service for restaurants who would drop
off industrial sized cans of tuna that I
would survive on for weeks almost like
I'm gonna die of mercury poisoning you
know
um but that thing like that thing the
struggle to the success
tell me I know I know your story but can
you give me like the brief like struggle
to success story yeah I mean you talk
about tuna you know when I was in the
Army I would get the tuna because it was
disgusting but the can was like 49 cents
at PX and you would mix it with mustard
because at least mustard would make it
tolerable and throughout the day I would
have three four five of these cans to
get the protein protein no listen
regular tuna might be the key to the
whole operation I think that's what it
is with Mercury we're both going to go
through one day news is going to come
out Dave Rubin and Patrick David are
dealing with Mercury having too much of
it but no I mean look you know it all
starts with a dream I was talking to a
couple of the guys the other day just
yesterday we're doing a zoom call with a
couple of our executives
and one of my guys says uh hey one of my
sales guys I'm dealing with he's very
difficult to deal with he's a pain in
the ass and he's tough to do this he's a
1099 guy not W-2 W2 you have the option
to Fire and coach and send them to
places but 1099 you're working with
these guys right it's like you're
running a insurance office and real
estate office so he says what do I do
with them I said well let me tell you
what I do in these types of situations
I said for a guy like me I joined the
army at 18 okay April 15 1997 I get
shipped to uh Fort Jackson South
Carolina
my ASVAB score wasn't high so I Only
Could Be infantry or mechanics so I
became a Hummer mechanic I had 13
Hummers to myself I had a couple fmtvs
and lmtvs these are the bigger trucks
and I had a hotel 8 certification which
means I can go tow cars out of the mud
you know trucks out of the mud and
that's what I did for a living I thought
I was going to do 20 years
literally I'm going to be in the yard
before 20 years then I'm going to get
out I'm going to get an additional 10
points on my uh score to be working at
the post office or cop or firefighter
because if you're a former military you
get that 10 points on the test so if
somebody scores 75 but you're in the
Army you get 85. if you do 82 you do 92
right so that advantage
then one day I get a call from a friend
of Mike Hogan he says hey Pat what are
you doing I said tomorrow I'm
re-enlisting for six years uh really
yeah I'm really listening tomorrow they
got me everything I wanted my orders I'm
going to go special forces Delta Sears
school you know I speak five languages
so they're gonna help me out to sharpen
my language and then I'm going to go to
Vicenza Italy which is where I wanted to
go to there was a beautiful unit there
and then from there you know I'm gonna
do this for 20 years then I'm going to
retire at 38 years old and then I'm
gonna go be a cop in firefighter he says
Pat you got to get out I said I'm not
getting out I'm signing my contract to
more for six years and I'm getting my
Army accommodation met I had gotten an
Army Achievement medal tomorrow was a
celebration Lieutenant Colonel peacocks
was going to give me an army
accommodation medal he says can I
convince you otherwise I said you can't
my dad already sent me a 250 camera as a
gift for committing to re-enlist he says
just give me an hour and this guy was
the only guy that ever came and visited
me in the Army out of my friends for 18
days and when you're in the Army you're
alone you remember all the letters I
kept every letter every single letter
anybody ever wrote me while I was on
boot camp I have all of it till today
all of it you know like who was a friend
and who's thinking and who's not all of
them the people he thought that your
best they never wrote you a letter the
people you thought were like they were
okay they wrote you 50 60 letters
so I'm sitting there hour later it's now
one o'clock in the morning I got
formation early in the morning I can't
sleep all night I've already promised my
dad I'm on a realist he wants me to stay
in uniform being a military I get out in
the morning go to Lieutenant Colonel
peacocks disappointing news for you I
can't re-enlist I got to get out but
David what are you doing we got you the
orders I said I totally under you you
have no clue how much I respect you but
I'm getting outside get out they don't
give me the Army accommodation medal how
difficult were those I mean I'm thinking
about it right now I'm going back
because I throw my boots over the you
know you you celebrate like hey this is
it it wasn't easy let me tell you it was
a lot of anxiety because when you're in
the military it's so regimented it's so
like routine and if you like routine
there's a lot of trust and comfort in
routine there's order there's
expectation there's a time for formation
it's a lot of good things your benefit
child Hall when you eat how much you get
paid your promotions correspondence
courses you got to take you know you'll
be an E5 E6 E7 eventually you'll be a
drill sergeant maybe you know first
sergeant that's our major E9 and that's
kind of the route you go and you can
take advantage of GI Bill maybe become
an officer or second Lieutenant first
lieutenant work your way up so there was
an immediately you can travel see the
world it was you know 20 years what it's
going to look like it's predictable
and I like the predictable aspect but I
also have a uncertainty aspect the
unknown fires me up there's an element
of unknown that's exciting that the
level of curiosity I want to know what
the possibilities are
so then I get out I get out of the
military I come out to be a Hummer
mechanic and there was one shop at
Camarillo and it was Thousand Oaks
Camarillo that had a Hummer dealership
so I go and I said listen I'm the best
summer mechanic in Fort Campbell
Kentucky and the guy says listen man we
sell maybe one or two Hummers a month
each one we have one mechanic if we're
lucky we don't need a second one and I
say I'm very good at shooting he says
listen we don't need a Hitman here you
know you're not going to use it in
private
so at that point I want to took the test
to be a cop I had 16 speeding tickets so
I couldn't be a cop and then firefighter
there was a hold and then boom five year
freezing being a firefighter then I get
out and start making money in the
financial sector Morgan Stanley uh
Transamerica then I start my own
insurance company and the rest is
history the point I was making with this
meeting was the level of Grace God has
on us when you go back and think about
the people you met in your life some of
them were they made such a big impact in
your life but they're a five minute
person in your life you're at
Nordstrom's your son is wrestling with
you a woman over here who's 65 years old
looking at me for 10 minutes while me
and Dylan are wrestling I said ma'am how
you doing she's I'm doing good he said
do you know why I'm looking at you I
said why are you looking at me this is
because I remember when my kids were
that age
so tell me about your kids I have three
sons how they doing what do they do
one's a doctor one's an engineer and
one's a lawyer really all successful all
successful all married with kids all
married with kids give me three Secret
Sauce what was it so I only give you one
I said what's that
she says if you ever threaten to
discipline your kids follow through
I was like out of all the advice you can
give you give me this if you threaten
them always follow through because your
word can't lose weight yeah this is five
years ago I'm at Nordstrom's that lady
was in my life for five minutes that
impact is permanent you got certain
people that are one day certain people
that are a month certain people that are
a year certain people that are a decade
but if you think like if you have a
relationship with the man upstairs and
say how did this person come into my
life what is the chance of me meeting
this person or that what I'm the
luckiest man alive so when you look at
it from that perspective and then now
when I wake up in the morning at the
beginning you and I were you know joking
about poisoning the drink and I told you
I said if God takes me today man I've
lived the most incredible life I am so
grateful everything from here is dessert
and bonus and you know that's that's a
brief uh element of the story I haven't
told before do you try to acknowledge
that every day I sense that you do from
watching your show and just watching
what you're doing on Instagram because
I've noticed for me and maybe this is
partly just being a new father like I I
really am like things have been good
like I don't want anything else it's
good it's really good I'm doing what I'm
supposed to be doing I have the family
I'm supposed to have I'm like I'm like
unbelievably humbled by that and I don't
know what to do with it sometimes in a
way it's it's interesting you say that
so to me this is the battle I have right
because I have friends of mine who made
their money that no longer want to work
and they're living the life where it's
like well you know Kobe had the father
time that came you know LeBron's father
time is coming I'm kind of going through
the father time myself people will say
this right
and I'll say cool to each his own
totally respect this salute to you but I
can't help myself I tend to challenge
everybody around me Family Friends kids
if you're around me you're either gonna
like it because I'm gonna challenge you
or you're not gonna like it you know
because you're gonna listen too much man
I can't be around this guy too much
because it's constantly like the next
level the next thing yeah but you have
to realize how as tough as I am on
everybody else
I'm a lot tougher on myself the way I
process this is the following way
I'm I'm greedy and selfish in the
following way I watched the movie Meet
Joe Black that completely messed me up
I've never seen a movie Meet Joe
Blackville two months ago at Brad Pitt
right but I don't think I've seen it oh
yeah I mean listen let me tell you I
can't tell you how ridiculous this movie
is okay the Vault conference we held
with Brady a lot two weeks ago yeah I
talked about me Joe Black for two three
days because the scene opens up with
Brad Pitt shows up and Brad Pitt is
death I'm not going to give you the
whole story but he says I'm death and he
keeps rubbing his chest you know Anthony
Hopkins one of the greatest actors of
all time because he's having a heart
attack
and death comes and says your time is
here you're about to die he's 65 years
old his oldest daughter is putting
together the big party presidents are
showing up senators are showing up
billionaires are showing up and here's a
businessman that's a billionaire gets in
a helicopter from Hamptons goes to
Manhattan does business comes back and
you know that's the life he's living and
he's so close with his daughters they
love him youngest daughter is kind of
like his right-hand person that's doing
stuff with a business and she's dating
the other right-hand guy and this house
is like a behemoth 60 000 square foot
house and impact Investments board
and I'm watching this movie I'm like
oh my God fired me up because it gave me
urgency because my dream was always to
have the family live close I want all my
kids close to me obviously they don't
have to they get to do whatever they
want to do but I'm gonna bust my tail to
have so many different opportunities
where if you want to be a realtor you
can manage our real estate portfolio if
you want to be a lawyer we need lawyers
if you want to go to movies let's go
find your movies if you want to go be a
teacher let's build a school together
they could be dog walkers because I saw
a video that you did anything where your
kids are now making some money yeah dog
walking and you want to be a capitalist
go do it but let's stay together because
I want us to stay together as a family
and I'm going to do my best to create
that net and then at the same time the
other side you know I wrote this book
called choose your enemies wisely
that comes out December 5th a lot of
people say you know why choose your
enemies wisely why not choose your
friends wisely why not choose your
allies wisely I really think
this is a season where enemies
are truly formidable enemies that
requires people who are capable to fight
to stand up and I take that role very
seriously I teach my kids that somebody
in school is getting bullied and you can
do something about it you got to stop
that if you don't you're a coward so in
a way if I'm teaching this to my kids
and I'm watching what's going on in
America what's going on with the you
know these guys telling Rumble what to
do from House of Commons hey you guys
better take this guy down and consider
what YouTube did to them from UK is
telling Rumble a Canadian company based
out of who the hell are you to say
something or what they're doing to
parents and you got 30 different cities
who are in Canada protesting right now
against indoctrinating kids and have so
much respect for these parents that are
willing to do the fight I'm sorry some
people maybe don't have a platform like
you and I who am I to want to sit here
and just celebrate all this money I've
made the house I have the you know
relationships I have I feel like
I feel like this is an era where God is
looking for you know the the flag
carriers to rise up and and we feel we
want to be we want to earn the right to
be one of them did you have to do work
to not feel guilty over success because
the the mainstream idea of success
everyone wants to pretend it's only
worthwhile if you came from nothing it's
really worthwhile if you have nothing if
you're always struggling but if you came
from anything or you have anything you
should be guilty about it or feel bad
about it and I actually remember the
first time that I went to your show
which was soon after moving to Florida
and it was so you guys loved success so
much and obviously the last couple years
have been good to me and it has been a
shift in my mind to not feel any shame
around it I feel Pride over it I mean I
built this I work with great people I
talk to people like you but it's like
you have to like do work to do that
because you have to overcome what
Society is telling you about success you
know it's a great point I read a book
once by a man named Art Williams a man I
look up to a lot he's a great leader he
went from being a regular guy in the
insurance industry build a company
became a billionaire bought an NHL team
and just great Family Guy I think he's
been married for 50 something years to
his wife if not longer and he's impacted
a lot of people's lives in one of his
books he says never feel guilty for the
work others have to do to win in life
and I read this at 30 years old 29 30
years old I got a hold of this book
that's very hard to get a hold of it he
wrote a couple books one is called
pushing up people another one is called
uh all you can do is all you can do but
all you can do is enough but this book
is not a CL you can't buy it in
bookstore so I got a hold of it
and it said uh never feel guilty I'm
like never feel guilty
never feel guilty wow hey that guy's got
to pay the price as well if he says he's
got this big dream he's got to pay the
price so never feel guilty what a point
kids never feel guilty if your kid wants
it he's got to pay the price yesterday
Jay Williams you know Jay Williams the
the basketball player together till
midnight he's at the house he's talking
to Tico to Dylan Dylan's an athlete so
he wants to play sports super
competitive success so uh Dylan so tell
me tell me about yourself he says well I
play this this this this that he says
how good are you he says I'm I'm a good
athlete but I'm a little too competitive
sometimes and I want to win all the time
he said let me show you a video he shows
the video he sits down on the stairs and
he's showing Dylan this video Jay
Williams talking to Tom bilio on impact
theory about a story of Kobe Bryant this
video went viral and he says one day
we're shooting I'm doing 400 shots I
wasn't going to leave till I make the
phone you've probably seen this video
yeah I've seen it yeah and Dylan's like
in Amber bite we're just kind of
watching this and he's like wow that's
pretty wild on what you know Kobe did to
get to where he's at so then he's
teaching my son
hey if you really want to go there
you're going to have to pay the price
because this guy paid a price I can't
feel guilty for my son having to pay the
price
so so if others don't want to do it I
don't feel guilty for you so then the
next phase becomes for us is
you came from nothing you're broke when
you're doing this you know comedy stand
up and then now you're living in an
incredible home here and you have a
weight your voice carries weight where
people want your endorsement people want
to see what Dave has to say you've
spoken to some of the most powerful
names around the world and you are many
people's dreams one day people want to
follow your footsteps where they got to
pay the price for but the challenge is
going to be for our kids our kids are
going to go through the other part well
listen you're you're a rich kid and
you're this and you're that and you're
this I'm reading this book by Joseph
Kennedy and Joseph Kennedy in his book
when you read it one of the things he
didn't want to do is never wanted to
give credit to his parents because he
wanted to say I did it myself so you
know as you go into this phase our kids
challenge is going to be different than
ours last night I'm really challenging
one of my kids hardcore right now and my
wife and I are having a conversation
because we're reading musk's notebook
phenomenal book by the way I don't know
if you've gone through it yet I haven't
gone through it yet phenomenal
phenomenal just a very it just came out
a couple days it just came out it just
came out the story with him Kimball
sister two hours he would walk to this
and how he would get into fights and
bullied and the way his dad was and why
he lived with his dad and Kimball which
is a very interesting story and it's
like babe you know I said babe you need
to listen to this book because you have
to know one of our kids wired this way
so we have to understand him better and
she says but you know you think we're
being a little bit too tough I said babe
if life is going to be everything's
going to be easy and perfect and no
challenges like we need to create a
little bit of challenges for our kids to
be tougher and that's the element of as
a parent we need to be creative and
that's not easy to do because we have
the resources to make their lives very
easy it's going to be very challenging
for us and then we at the same time need
to have them have their own identity so
but one of the lessons I learned is I we
can't feel guilty for the price others
have to pay does the fame part feel
weird to you because I mean you were an
insurance guy and a business guy and you
were giving business talks and now it's
like you're talking to presidential
candidates and all the people I'm
talking to I was a comedian like the
idea of Fame was like built into the I
never was doing it to be maybe
subconsciously I was I wasn't
consciously doing it that way but like
Fame was going to be an extension of
what I did you go into insurance
you're not going I'm going to be famous
one day yeah yeah no listen to be famous
in Insurance it means nothing it means
you need something really illegal for
you to be wow what a famous insurance
agent right the way he signed that
contract is just incredible right that
guy moved a lot and freaking on the
paper there is no like sports center
David watch the way he signed his
insurance policy there's no such thing
like that right so it's kind of weird so
no I but I think what I like about it is
the evolution of it where it wasn't
sudden what is very tough is no one
knows who you are and boom here we go
like Dion Sandra son right now you're
seeing the amount of Fame he's getting
yeah but he's had the best mentor to
coach him for Bianca's Dion was you know
the face you know the greatest athlete
yeah I would say of all time what he's
done just athlete not winner athlete the
greatest I put him number one I put bow
two I put LeBron three the greatest win
owners of all time I got MJ and Brady at
the top then it's a company purely
because this is not just purely to sport
athleticism oh is 40 his is the way he
played you're hitting 324. yeah for the
Atlanta Braves and you know how hard
yeah 92 93.9 that whole team with I
think it was Pendleton galaraga all
those guys that they had David Justice I
think that's the year all the crazy
pictures smolds yeah Maddox they had so
yeah but but to me some people don't
have the coaching of Fame so you see
some of these guys on social media where
all of a sudden get Fame and they start
acting dumb and they act uh you know but
you know we have to also be patient for
some of them because they're going to go
through it for us the advantage we have
is it's not like all of a sudden a
thousand people are waiting outside
saying oh my God name it starts off with
are you that guy yeah you start off with
that guy where you look like that you
look like that guy like Dave Rubin I'm
like wow you know what I love to see us
and it's actually my twin bro I can't
stand the guy if you only knew who he
was you wouldn't like him as much
because you need to know the truth about
him but no the benefit we have it's
Evolution it's slow it's gradual then
there is the boom but by that time
you've been you've been trained can I
tell you the wackiest one of those that
I saw was a guy that you've interviewed
and met many times Jordan Peterson you
know what I was touring with him for a
year and a half and think about it this
guy's a clinical psychologist so he
spent most of his life he was teaching
also but spent most of his life helping
people get off drugs one-on-one like
this privately then he becomes basically
the most famous person in the world
overnight
and everywhere we went we'd get to
airports in Sweden and there'd be 200
people waiting for us because they got
their life in order and he would talk to
every single one of them I never saw the
guy be rude or ignore or walk away from
anybody and it was like but I will tell
you this jeez but I'll tell you this
I also will say he also didn't know how
to handle it to an extent hear me out so
I was with him during that yeah so I
remember not not from the you know
arrogant and I'm not talking that side
at all I'm talking about
you know one day I'm having them on and
for about 30 minutes he talked about how
much Tweeds bother him yeah
and he really didn't like what people
were saying on Twitter and I was kind of
shocked by him saying this this is five
years ago first time I had him on the
show and then I brought him back at an
event in 2019 at the Mirage this is the
event where we had President Bush Kobe
Bryant the late Kobe Bryant
this is that event and he's speaking and
he's crying half the time
I'm like he's going through something
and I asked him a couple questions I'm
like he's going through something that's
the last interview he does and then he
goes through the phase that he went
through and he openly talked about how
he dealt with it how challenging it was
for him and then the The Comeback on
what he's done and what his daughter's
done uh both of them I mean they're
they're former obviously Jordan Peterson
is a Powerhouse he's a you know force of
Nature and he's duplicating it with his
daughter and that's where the respect
goes that your daughter is carrying the
torch and I can only imagine where she's
going to be later on in life she's
already crushing it but imagine what
that's going to be in 10 years so I want
to talk to you about that Kobe thing we
talked about it one other time when you
were on the show but it's what so you
basically did the last bit was it the
last interview it was certainly the last
big interview yes Kobe were both
basketball guys we we picked our top
fives I still think mine beats yours but
that's where we do that later uh but
Kobe when the day I think maybe I told
you this privately can't remember two or
three days before he died I was watching
uh just flicking the channels and I
flipped past I lived in L.A at the time
and I flipped past Comcast sports or
whatever whatever the Lakers are on and
I saw Kobe and I hadn't seen him a lot I
had a beard and he looked like a million
bucks that was my thought he looks like
a million bucks and I stopped and I
watched and just the way he spoke that
calmness that he spoke with and always
licking his lips like he was just ready
to chew the world and I watched for
about five minutes and I swear to God
this is true I remember thinking this is
a guy who has done life right
that was either the day or two days
before he did and then the day he died I
saw it on Twitter I immediately began to
tear up I was actually I was on tour
with Jordan at the time I was about to
get in uh an Uber I get in the Uber and
it's a young black guy as the driver
he's hysterical crying because he must
have just found out at that moment
hysterical crying I said to him I know I
know it's Kobe I know and I was very
early so I said well we don't have to go
anywhere for a while you want to just
talk about Kobe for a while and we spent
about a half hour get out of here I
swear to God just talking about the 81
point game the coming you know the
Denver game when he flew in after the
league like everything everything and I
remember thinking like man that guy
two days ago I'm thinking he's living
the dream he's done whatever the secret
of the universe is he unlocked it
gone like that and you sat with him and
had one of the I think one of the best
interviews that he's ever had I don't
even know what my question is other than
what do you do with that yeah what do
you do with that concept yeah you know
Kobe's in August 23rd 1978 baby I'm in
October 18 1978 baby we're six weeks
apart I remember since I'm 76. you're 76
but you look younger than me you look
you look better than me the moisture
here
so so when he came and they traded him
for vlades obviously we were devastated
we didn't want to lose bloody because
vladi's a top five Center greatest
Center of all time uh hence the sarcasm
wow that didn't get by me come on top
five Center he was good he was a good
passer yeah
he scored the points put his hands
behind his back he won two Magic Johnson
I just love a lot I would have never
lived that down if I had missed that
yeah that would have been
so so you know top five Czechoslovakia
or or Yugoslavia yeah and by the way I
think it's a GM or something for
Sacramento I don't know if I don't know
if he still is or not but I I like his
swag and those Sacramento teams are
awesome yeah phenomenal him Christy and
all those guys you know stoyakovich
great team but you know it was like I'm
gonna go with this place I'm not an
athlete you're gonna go this place but
listen man I'm gonna bring the Mamba
mentality in my own way in the insurance
space and boom and then later on 2019
there's a video of me dressed as doc
from uh Back to the Future
and it's a video I'll show it to you
afterwards because it's not public and
I'm saying one day this is 2011. I have
docs here I'm wearing the whole thing
this event we're running I brought the
DeLorean I'm doing a whole skit from
stage with myself and a couple of our
guys John Fred Terrace and all these
guys we're doing what we're doing
and I said one day 2011. I haven't
started YouTube channel yet and I said
one day the great Kobe Bryant will be on
our show and we'll be having an
interview
so that Vision was casted eight years
later Kobe's at the event or guys can't
believe this is happening
and he comes in hour and a half we spent
in a conference room together before he
hits the stage he talks to dinner for 15
minutes
Dylan at the time was five years old he
talks to Jen for 15 minutes is that the
best conversation together then a 70
year old woman 75 year old woman comes
in very nicely put together and he runs
up to her they hug each other and they
have the nicest conversation where you
can tell the level of respect and love
he has for her and I don't know who she
was but there was a certain level of uh
uh relationship towards each other and
he says uh so Pat Uh do these types of
interviews live make you nervous I said
nah I'm good me neither I played in
front of 20 000 people I said no I
totally get it I mean you're Kobe I
don't see you but I'm good at this point
that we hit the stage a thousand people
run up we have to call the security the
benefit we had because the president was
coming we had 100 Secret Service so
everything was pushing him out and we
sat down we did the interview and
obviously the rest is history but the
day when he passed away we were at
Seasons 52 in Dallas and Plano and my
phone says Kobe Bryant helicopter
Jennifer looks like and like what
then I go to ESPN what Twitter because
you know sometimes
and then Dylan is like wait my friend
Kobe so yeah I mean I was pretty wild
but you know what it is what you're
saying here
that's the whole concept where
you have to enjoy the process even when
you're in the grind driving
to know that at any point this can be
taken away from you yeah just enjoy it
because in some ways people take that
message and say that that's why I don't
work that hard why it's the purpose of
working that hard if I know I'm going to
die one day why am I doing all this
stuff that's also not the right way of
thinking I want to work hard with the
people I love
and using the talents that God gave me
but if he takes me today I'm good as
well because at the end of the day you
have no clue what that day is going to
be do you uh do you consider yourself
political because we're crossing paths
now a lot and and the type of people
that are watching us are very similar in
the political sense of things but I can
never tell if you really are political
like I saw you at the GOP debate that's
a pretty political thing I go on your
show we talk about politics uh you wait
you didn't do the DeSantis thing yet
right it was it was scheduled
three times the hurricane yeah also
because he was he was going to you and
that he was coming to me that afternoon
right and then and then the hurricane
hit but but obviously you're you're
political and the things that you talk
about but do you consider yourself a a
political person what does a political
person mean well that you really like
you like you really like the game of
politics oh I really like the uh not
like you you're passionate about the
issues like you really think about all
of the issues and I do my parents got a
divorce you know so I watch these guys
get two divorces and remarry each other
twice right and she was what baby my
parents got me they're married and
divorced they got married my sister's
born they get a divorce two years later
they remarry I'm born then they get a
divorce again that's mine and that was
it though
they can't you if they're in the same
room they're going to resurrect the guy
on that one yeah so I mean but my
mother's side a lot of them were
Communists and my dad said a lot of them
were imperialists these guys love the
shot they hated the shop these guys you
know loved capitalism they hated
capitalism they loved Karl Marx that was
their Bible Stalin he was a great leader
for Russia USSR all these rich greedy
people in America all they care about is
money we care about family why would you
work that hard you should come home and
come home at three o'clock and have
watermelon and cheese and cut it up and
sit down and have a conversation
together who cares about the car you
drive who cares about this this this is
that and I watched it so for me
I I didn't like politics because I saw
the fact that the two people I loved the
most got a divorce because of politics
but that was really it is
political oh my God I mean one of them
their philosophy was rich people are
greedy you know they care about is money
and the other one was poor people are
lazy like you just can't get over that
it's just like and that was just
ingrained and but at that time it wasn't
politics it was more like why did these
guys why'd you guys get married in the
first place and thank God you did but
why'd you get married in the first place
what was the whole purpose behind it so
then I go to Germany and then we come to
the states
and when I come to the states I go to
the Army and then I'm that was the first
time where military you know stuff was
going on President Bush and Clinton and
all this kind of stuff was going on and
I'm like interesting what's going on
here then I went into financial services
and started competing and then I
realized politics is involved in
insurance department of insurance
politics is involved in being a cop
being a firefighter running a business
regulation financial industry SEC nasd
it's involved everywhere and then when
we were a small insurance company
politics doesn't do anything for you or
not you're small nobody cares who you
are you're tiny then we got bigger and
then all of a sudden we have a business
that's National we're appointed in 49
states and we have offices all over the
country a few hundred offices then you
notice there's a lot of politics
involved all the guys that were all nice
to you and now they're like you know oh
you can build anything you want you can
be as big as you want and then they're
like oh he actually became as big
as they wanted now it's like you took
business away from us and you're this
and you're done like oh so there is
politics then you go and you start study
and had dinner with George Will in 2009
March with Claremont Institute and I go
to this event and I watch what you know
he's talking about with Larry Arn and
Larry Greenfield and all these guys and
I'm going to these events with the owner
of public storage at you know Malibu and
I'm having these meetings with John
Voight and you know Larry uh Dennis
Prager is coming then I launch a show in
2009 with kklak rla called saving
America a year later I shut it down
because my San Francisco office closed
down they said I cannot believe you
started a show and you know how dare you
do this kind of I'm like wait a minute
what's going on with politics then one
day I'm in my office in Woodland Hills
yeah who is this yeah you're you owe uh
you know tax assessor we're here yours
85 whatever 85 000 for what you're in a
district you have to pay you're growing
your business has grown this is how much
money you are so what are you talking
about I call my accountant was
downstairs under you know our floor
eighth floor I say what is this all
about he says well if they catch you and
they're coming around they knock on
doors that are growing it's Hit or Miss
if they don't come to you don't have to
pay it wow but if they come to you and
they know you're a grown business they
can tax you you're in this District I
said are you serious so we have to pay
this check then I said what districts
don't they have this 13 of them
Victorville Santa Monica Burbank I said
okay I'm gonna go to Burbank Glendale so
we move our headquarters to Burbank
Glendale so I don't have to worry about
this and we're in Glendale the New York
Life building and then all of a sudden
I'm like no we're not staying here
um Time Magazine comes out with the
article United States of Texas
then we go to Texas we have a meeting
with Governor Perry with mayor masso
from Frisco who's the fastest growing
city in Texas then we go to a Rangers
game with Nolan Ryan and we watch how
these guys are recruiting businesses to
Texas this is when Rick Perry would go
to California with the radio shows if
you don't like the business they're
taking care of you we're going to take
care of you here in Texas and we're like
okay great so then we moved to Texas we
fell in love with Texas
and then covet happens politics goes to
whole different level my content was
always around business Mafia interviews
it was not a political thing then all of
a sudden
politics becomes relevant on what we're
doing with covet and then I said no
we'll see
your politics were probably you were
kind of right leaning in that you were
probably for example government right
less regulation less taxes then covet
hits that's what basically drove us both
here yes I had a pretty freaking good
life in L.A and then on whatever that
day was March 17th or whatever it was
two weeks to stop the spread day two
I was like this place is never coming
back and you know I fought very hard I
campaigned with Larry Elder for the
recall and I don't know if I've told you
this you know that three days after the
recall you know what happened you talk
about getting a knock on your door from
the tax man I got audited by the state
of California after I publicly was
backing larielle during campaigning
makes sense I put my house for sale that
day that day like that tells you all you
need to know so isn't that a weird thing
about how your your life
better match up with your politics
otherwise
yeah you're in a lot of trouble see I
have a problem with that because for me
and what I mean by I have a problem with
that it's not a problem with bullies uh
I'm a you know
so here's what's going on today you know
believe it or not the majority
will forgive people lying to them the
government liked them they'll get over
it they'll cry about it but they'll get
over it the majority will even tolerate
being taken advantage of I mean if you
think about it it's been going on
America I can't believe you're doing it
you're not going to do nothing about it
you're going to go back to your state in
California and not leave and California
is going to be you ain't leaving anyways
so stop you will tweet about it angrily
but you're not going to do it nothing
there is no action it's just yeah yeah
watch watch what I'm gonna do watch oh
yeah I'm going to punch you in the face
go ahead yeah
I know you get back in your car and you
leave right that's most people in
California
but here's the problem
you cross the line with kids yeah you
just woke up an animal
because a mother went through 40 weeks
so mothers automatic most vested thing
you're going to be in your life is
carrying a a human being for 40 weeks
you haven't gone through the pain you
want to groom my kids
I'm good man we're not going to do this
all of a sudden what the hell happened
to this guys you know rage I've never
seen you be like this what happened to
all these mothers what happened to all
these parents California UK you know
taxes New York what they're waking up so
here's the part
for most part most people there's a
saying that says whatever you don't hate
you learn to tolerate
maybe just don't like it you know but a
few of us
have a lower tolerance level for you
cross on the line what do you before I
want you to continue but what do you
think that is about us
like now I know now as a father I know a
new layer of it but what do you think
that is what do you think it is about
you that is just like I will be one of
the people that will call out the
yeah uh I I don't I don't know how to
answer that question I would say for me
uh uh it's it's either in your DNA it's
either you know you've gone through
losing things in the past or you've had
a moment in your life where you weren't
paranoid and you lost it all and you're
like damn I should have been paranoid or
you were too tolerant and things were
taken away from you or you were kind of
like yeah he's gonna be here all the
time and then boom he's no longer he
dies or she dies
so you have a different level of parent
like when you read musk's book you
realize why he's doing what he's doing
because the pain he's gone through some
of us have lived a harder life where we
you know we we are willing to use that
pain to do something about it but what I
am saying is the fact that the the so I
used to pray for four things right for
longest time it's always been as David
family we lead respect we improve we
love we don't get bullied and we don't
bully and we pray for four things
courage wisdom tolerance understanding
courage because if your vision has been
you're going to do something but you're
going to face certain things that you
don't know how to handle you need
courage wisdom if you're planning on
leading everybody you're going to
sometimes lead people smarter than you
and older than you you need wisdom
tolerance because you know people are
annoying at times you got to tolerate
them and last but not least
understanding everyone's dealing with
something so it's good to have some
understanding right but the tolerance
part I'm not praying about it anymore I
skipped through it I said God I ask you
to give me courage wisdom and
understanding I don't want tolerance why
not the reason why I don't want
tolerance is because
tomorrow I have a big show on uh PPD
podcast
and I'm by the way we've been working on
this for months and it got ugly but we
finally pulled it off I have two Muslims
coming on the podcast and I have two
Christians coming on the podcast
till this morning it wasn't happening
both Camp backed out and backed out and
we had to change some names because they
couldn't get their passports
but we finally got him to be here
tomorrow okay so we're doing this
conversation together
and
my goal is
we can have a friendly conversation you
know what about this with Prophet
Muhammad what about this with you know
Jihad and what about this with
Christians this and what about this one
and what about this and what about this
no problem
what do Jews Christians and Muslims have
in common that's my interest we can have
the religion debate let's do it great by
the way
everybody could be wrong and everybody
could be right and only one person could
be right yeah and we don't know that's
why it's called Faith yeah faith is
believe it is something that we have not
seen right it's Faith now I'm a man of
faith I believe in God the risk I'm
taking is being non-denominational
Christian I could be wrong but that's
what I'm banking on right I will not
know till I die now there's been many
moments in my life to validate that I've
chosen the right Faith but that's
one-on-one right I can't I can simply
tell my testimony you can say you know
what what a powerful testimony let me
consider it as well but it's one-on-one
right okay
look what's going on uh like when I
study numbers I'm like how are 74 of
Muslims voting Democrat
makes no sense to me how
how why are Christians so critical of
the Muslim religion
yet just so you know Christians by 2060
the world's gonna have 10 billion people
three billion is going to be a Muslim
that's 31 and most of the senate in the
house will be Muslims how could you say
something like that because they have
2.9 kids per woman and you don't
because they have more kids than you
because they're more vested in their
faith and more intolerant about
disrespecting their faith and Christians
are more tolerant Christians more look
what's happening in Glendale the place
that you used to work
no no but but the Muslims and Armenians
of of Glendale decided to stand up again
yeah and that's exactly and the left
didn't know what to do with it and I
love that that's my whole purpose the
premise of what I'm trying to do with
these guys tomorrow
I trust it's going to be fiery but I'm
going to ask questions that I'm going to
say look if if religions where you want
to compete then go have more kids you're
not doing it you're going to lose just
so you know you're going to lose because
they don't tolerate disrespect to their
religion you do
they have more kids they believe in
having more kids and spreading their
values and principles you don't you're
going to lose it's just going to happen
if it goes this way now that's one part
set that aside what's the other part
Muslims why 74 Democrat why
just because of one policy
you vote them just because of one policy
what's the one policy just because
Republicans are a little bit more
pro-israel so you go this way seriously
that's the only reason which by the way
on the warfront the parties have
completely flipped but that completely
yeah right so so I'm trying to get that
the argument yeah I'm trying to get that
conversation for them to are you on the
same page with XYZ yes right on the same
page but what's going on yes are you
pro-marriage are you pro-family are you
pro-bus are you Pro that yes listen guys
what are we doing because the scariest
thing is going to happen to Global is
and the establishment if all of a sudden
they see Jews Christians and Muslims
being on the same page thinking like
wait a minute guys no no no you guys
can't get along yeah we've worked so
hard to make sure you guys hate each
other we have to keep these guys hating
each other spread a rumor bring an old
tweet did you see what he said about
Jews did you see what he said about
Muslims did you see what he said about
Christians and I said yeah let's talk
more fire and that's why we can't like
this guy I'm trying to get these guys
because of Christians Jews and
Christians Christian Jews and Muslims
come like this
I think they're going to be shivering
saying how the hell do we go up against
these guys can I give you a good one
that maybe you can drop with these guys
tomorrow is that I took my whole team we
did a week in Israel and then we went to
Hungary and we went to Jerusalem first
four days in Jerusalem guess what the
most surprising thing about Jerusalem
was saying it wasn't religion obviously
there's religious people
it was the peace there are Muslim women
in hijabs walking next to ultra-orthodox
Jewish guys hats
Muslim nurses going to school and the
Jews walking by and Orthodox Christians
and Greek Orthodox and everyone's doing
it and yes some bad stuff happens
occasionally find out what should happen
in Chicago this weekend and it's far
worse but the level of coexistence and
peace yeah it felt peaceful to me that's
what I kept saying to the guys well
isn't this I love it I love that
peaceful and that's the thing that
you're basically asking for and looking
for yeah so I mean look at our show
right I mean you know I'm I'm talking to
Chris Cuomo and we're building a
relationship together I'm not supposed
to get along Chris Cuomo for a lot of
different things policy wise but then
I'm having conversations I've made fun
of that guy an awful lot on this I think
we all have and he's made fun of us and
by the way guess what game you know
we're we're I I'm okay with that I don't
care if you make fun of me I'm okay
sometimes you I deserve to be made fun
of sometimes you deserve to be made fun
of sometimes he deserves to be made fun
of that's part of the game you know when
you're playing basketball and you know
Barclay elbow was Jordan in the rip and
then Jordan does back hey you know what
I'm a competitor you are too great your
goal should be to kick my ass and my
goal is to give a fight now Barkley
never got a ring Jordan took it and the
two years he had a chance Elijah one
took it no problem that's right I see
that over there that's the first thing
there was another guy on that election
team thank you rexley a time 50 player
of all time you know well yes I would
say top 50 top top 20 of the 80s and 90s
I don't he's not top 20 20. I think he's
not tween he's not top 20 of all time
he's eight he's top 15 80s and 90s in my
opinion that guy was a month or 10-year
period I think his top 15. monster
monster 28 point season average you know
whatever so going back to it I think
it's okay to Grapple and fight I think
it's okay like you know one of the
things we can learn from the UFC
is these guys are talking to each
other and at the end of the fight they
get on their knees and they hug each
other like dude you have to know for
Showmanship Dana White needs a fight but
he's okay if you want to hug after the
fight but up until that point he wants
to fight we want the fight as fans we
want you to hate each other up till the
fight and then afterwards guess what we
all want to see as weird as this sound
you love these guys I'm gonna do this
I'm going to do it I'm going to do this
and then at the end of it hey boom Head
to Head we get emotional did you ever
see I haven't thought about this in 20
years did you ever see there was an
interview that Mike Tyson did after one
of his fights he beats somebody
senseless like you know at the peak of
Tyson when he was just six second fights
like he beat someone senseless I can't
remember who it was and remember Jim
Gray was the NBC Sports guy at the time
and they were just throw him out there
and Jim Gray was this little like little
kind of frail white guy he'd get in the
ring with all these big guys and he
looked afraid all the time and together
he'd be like what do you think of the
fight and Mike Tyson said exactly what
you just said he said he's got a family
to feed I've got a family to feed this
is what we do this is why we do it
that's the part and Jim Gray's line
dancer he wants yeah so but guess what
we don't want that answer be fortified
we want it after the fight we're okay
with that so so for for me I wanted to
create a safe space where people from
the left the right to Middle can come
and talk
people who are Democrats who don't want
to talk politics but their Sports their
TV their celebrities they feel safe
coming and talking right you know people
who are uh athletes they feel safe
coming and talking and you know doing
what they're doing but it's like you
know what I don't agree with Pat but
you're not like his approach I don't
agree with such and such but I like
their approach cool no problem so it's
more trying to go like this I think
we've gone like that I think we need to
bring so this book one of the best books
I've ever read that no one ever read you
know a guy sold seven copies and I
bought all seven of them this book is
called barbarians to bureaucrats written
by Lawrence Middle I've probably over
the last 13 years have probably sold 30
000 copies of this guy's book every
chance I get I recommend this book right
it was written like if you can get a
copy good for you it's hard to find one
so he talks about the evolution every
society and company goes through okay
so he says you know you know in every
great business there's three people
there is the entrepreneur the
businessman and the son of a okay
every great and he explains how Steve
Jobs had an element of a son of a
but you know the other guy was more the
product guy so okay
and he says so here's the evolution
first there's a prophet the prophet
sells a vision one day like that Jack ma
video we're going to build Alibaba
you've seen that video right it's like
one day he's the prophet Steve Jobs one
day we are different right you know it's
Benjamin Damon and air which I know
you're big on the movie Air son of akaro
right hey Michael no one's going to
remember us they're going to remember
you but you're gonna go through just
like you go up you're going to follow
we're going to be here for you and what
a freaking speech right when he gave him
that movie I got the chills when I I
watch a movie three times twice twice it
was powerful I saw it after you you were
so high on it I was like all right and
by the way the day after that when
Tucker uh because the movie came out
when Tucker was fired from Fox we sent
one of our guys and he was outside of
Tucker's house I can say now for three
days dropping a note saying pbdm by Tim
wants to make an offer to you oh and you
did make an offer we 100 made an offer
to we made it public offer we you know
every kind of offer but it is what it is
he's doing a great job right now he's a
formidable voice very necessary boy so
the point is
you know he says first there's a prophet
then there's the Barbarian
who's the guy that's wanted to go do the
fight then there's the Builder and
Explorer they build technology or they
explore a new market then there's the
administrator then comes the next phase
which is a problematic phase so Prophet
Barbarian Builder Explorer administrator
bureaucrat Aristocrat America today is
filled with bureaucrats and Aristocrats
Mitch McConnell Chuck Schumer Nancy
Pelosi these guys that I've been around
for so long they don't want to give up
their card of being a congressman or
Senator they're the aristocrats and
bureaucrats that are ruining America but
he says the way you save it when it's
about to fall is it meets synergist
Sinners just know how to revive revite
you know re-energize a nation a company
America today desperately needs more
synergists synergists are not about Sin
you're a you're an idiot what a
dumbass what a stupidness senators are
saying I disagree
but you have the right to agree with
here's what my thoughts are here's what
I believe so our goal as by attainment
is doing with the student PPD podcast
we're trying to bring these guys here if
you guys disagree cool let's talk about
it yeah right that's kind of what the
approach we're taking are you amazed
that these guys are holding on as long
as they're holding on when you see last
week Pelosi I'm running again Mitch
McConnell literally freezing up in front
of microphones yeah Feinstein doesn't
know where she is they have to tell her
what to say Biden obviously something's
wrong fetterman I mean the list goes on
and on and on and that's across Party
Line yeah by the way yeah like are you
amazed that it's just
or it's just that's that's kind of the
point that's the point I mean look at
this you know a lot of times when you
know uh the establishment of sports
wants to criticize the current players
right and they defend themselves from
the past because it's easy to do that
they never want to give credit to the
newer guys right that one video of Elon
musk's crime when he's doing a 60-minute
interview and he's like hey does it hurt
you the fact that these men were Your
Heroes and now they're criticizing you I
don't know if you've ever seen this or
not oh I don't think so
amazing it's amazing you have to watch
this this is when Tesla's like barely
coming up every day is being criticized
and he's crying he said does it hurt you
that these are men you respect and you
admired yes it hurts a lot that they're
saying what they're saying about you yes
and then you're like dude look what he's
built look what he's doing right so for
me I think I'm not surprised that that's
taking place but when he changes and we
need some bold leaders to have the
audacity to go out there and do the
fight and and they're gonna rise up they
they're going to rise up so that's
actually a great segue to a little of
the Trump DeSantis thing that I wanted
to do with you because you've mentioned
you mentioned before the scientists
they've moved it on you a couple times I
have no doubt it's gonna happen you've
you've met him privately okay fine my
sense with you and DeSantis is that you
like him a lot on policies you moved
here because of Florida you seem to
think he has some kind of marketing
thing and I think that's probably right
I think that's probably right that
there's a trump is a brilliant marketer
and it's kind of messy below the hood
and DeSantis the policies are below the
hood it's all great but there's a
marketing issue there is that what you
see is that kind of like a rough
estimation to kind of where well first
of all I made the sentence for some
things to you you sent the invite and I
was in Dallas I came I want to make sure
people know to give you the credit so I
was in Dallas I got on I came visit and
then we flew back to Dallas at an event
going on in Dallas if you remember that
so yeah so I mean look the other day I
had Larry Alderaan which you and I both
have a lot of respect and what he's done
right and Candace Owens uh was on same
week Elder and in Candace I asked Larry
I said Larry do you think the profile of
picking a candidate for president has
changed and I don't think it's changed I
said do you think maybe you're wrong no
you don't know what you're talking about
and we kind of got into a little it was
a friendly in our show even if I agree
with you I want a little bit of bad how
did you mean that question here's what I
meant Bob here's what I mean you know
how in 1964 whatever the year was when
uh was it 60 I think was 60 or 64 one of
those where Nixon didn't shave and it
was a first TV debate ever and the
sweaty one the sweaty one Kennedy one
that's probably it's got to be about 60
right yeah so he and the Nixon had you
know Nixon didn't sleep he had a four
o'clock you know and John F Kennedy
went tanning he slept 10 hours that
night had a good meal looked good calm
came crushed it right well guess what it
changed it went from needing a voice
because everybody's like listening to
the radio to now radio on your face oh
my God he looks to work on Nixon right
who's probably more qualified to be
president excellent Nixon was more
qualified to be president yeah but he
lost because the game changed so America
wanted to see somebody that was young
eccentric attractive well spoken calm
you know carried you know himself very
well okay today versus then if you go
back and study what percentage of the uh
campaign they funded the top people that
put the most money in their campaign
Trump is at the top I believe then I
want to say is John F Kennedy his dad
said he would spend all the money he has
to do the campaign he ended up spending
like 40 the entire campaign with their
own money Ray can spend like nine
percent or seven percent you know
obviously uh Al Gore not Al Gore uh Ross
Pro spent a lot of his own money
whatever with 50 Hillary Clinton zero
percent of her own money Biden zero
percent of our own money his money and
you know Obama pretty much these three
it's zero percent of their own money
those that are zero their establishment
okay that spends zero percent their
money because they owe the most favors
okay so today's profile to be a
president let's take a look number one
America
we are very close to the majority not
wanting a pro-establishment candidate
so to be an anti-establishment candidate
you need to have a few money
that's number one Bloomberg had a few
money more than any other candidate that
ever ran what was he missing charm okay
so you need to be able to persuade and
charm he couldn't do it can I tell you
something quick about Bloomberg which is
that I and I said this to Trump the
night that I met Trump that I believed
from day one and I really think I'm
right that Bloomberg only ran as a Decoy
for Biden that Biden was number one at
the time and they needed Biden to get
through the debates and they knew he
couldn't debate and he was crumbling and
all that and they needed to deflect so
they threw Bloomberg up there he
willingly did it because you remember
those two debates that he was in
terrible where but it was all about
whether he sexually harassed a secretary
and that's what they spent the entire
debate so instead of Biden having to
defend himself I I truly believe that
you know what Trump said to me when I
said it Trump goes he goes like this he
goes
he goes ah you're you know actually
that's pretty good and then he turns to
Melania he says Melania can you tell him
uh he says to me he says can you tell
her tell the first lady what you just
said I said it to Melania and she kind
of nods and he goes Bloomberg just hates
me
[Laughter]
regardless he was deficient of yeah the
stuff so if you look at the golf score
you got Fu money which causes you to not
be pro-establishment this is why Vivek
is getting some momentum right now this
is why RFK is getting momentum right and
this is why Trump won in 2016. this is
why Ross Pro got the kind of numbers
that he got that caused George Bush
Senior to lose and Clinton to win this
is why Reagan did well this is why JFK
did well and it was I can't go on you
get the idea right so you need charm
then you need to be able to
have a uh run rate of being uh having
fame or influence so Vivek a year ago
nobody knew who Vivek was some people in
our space too but most people didn't
know who vivec was a year ago right so
he started late
vivek's going to be a formidable
candidate in 2028 he's going to be
because he's going to continue whatever
he does next he's going to be having 10
times amount of followers he's going to
write a couple more books he's going to
do this he's going to do that he's going
to be ready for 2027 2028 okay
formidable candidate what's the next one
so we got Fu money we got charm we got
you know run rate of being famous okay
that your people know who you are then
policies okay policies
um if you take policies who do we put
out the top with policies Trump do we
put DeSantis Tim Scott Mickey Haley who
do we put out the top I think the
scientists can go against anybody with
policies I mean listen these record is
the best when it comes out to Florida
that's why you and I are here at the end
of people come and where do people go no
question about it that's the record and
then the last one is that that I added
to the list was being able to create an
issue that no one's thinking about and
let me explain what I mean by this and
I'm presenting this to Larry other and
saying ah you don't know what you're
talking about and by the way I may be
wrong yeah I may be wrong right so what
does this mean you know coming up with
an issue that no one's thinking about we
got to build a wall what we got to build
a wall to keep these rapists and all
this uh the hell is he talking about we
got to build I'm going to build a wall
and I'm going to make Mexico pay for it
this just got even crazier now when are
you going to build the wall Mexico is
going to pay for the wall
no one's like you know you sit there
you're like all right let me see what
are we going to campaign on uh Health
Care uh you know uh military foreign
policy oh the war or taxes or economies
no we're going to build a wall and
Mexico's going to pay for it no one's
even thinking about that right so the
average candidate that runs they hire
some you know uh uh political
you know consultant and then well here's
the what's resonating with the audience
and here's what you got to do okay great
so I think some of these guys just
listen to those Consultants too much and
it screws the whole thing so that's your
criticism he's listened to these guys
too much because the policy yeah you
obviously think is right oh he will so
you'll generally like oh listen let's
put them in a room with no cameras and
talk policies you know what he's going
to do you know what he's going to do
I've done it I've done it oh my God no I
mean I watched Newsom the other day on
CNN I don't know if you watch it 32
minutes I watched it we played abortion
it's a clinic he did a clinic so
evil it doesn't matter
he did a clinic the average person who
doesn't follow what the hell is going on
they're going to say this guy's
presidential he sits like this
just watch how he sits he sits no I get
it again he says so are you going to run
for office oh no why would I run for
office do you realize just two years ago
they recall me talk about being humble
I mean that's the kind of stuff that you
know is attractive to the average person
not the person that's the policy walk so
in a way do you think we will always
just get what we deserve in a weird way
because you're basically saying there
are people who are good enough to do it
who would do it right who would lead to
a more prosperous here's what I would be
society and then there's a show and how
do we Arbitrage those two things if I'm
running the RNC I'm the I'm the guy I'm
the guy that's running the RNC I
wouldn't take this job but I'm the guy
they don't pay that much I'm not here's
what I would do okay
one of the only speakers I've ever
brought to an event three times is Billy
Bean from Moneyball okay
he changed the game yeah won 21 games in
a row Brad Pitt played the movie you
know the whole man and what is it Jonah
Hill I think plays the the whatever the
guy that says the most important
statistic is not a home run the most
important it's on base percentage is
what it is like what are you talking
about no don't trade him yeah get that
guy why that guy 380 on base percentage
410 on base percentage what he doesn't
hit that well on base percentage he
knows how to get a walk he keeps his
elbow in he gets hit it's like
what the hell does an elbow have to do
with it trust me the only goal is to get
on base right I would bring in 20
analysts
and I would spend millions of dollars
and I would tell them put a golf score
put a list of 40 reasons why somebody
becomes a president of the last you know
50 years after TV and now let's do after
social media because those are two
different eras right so what caused this
guy to win and that guy to lose okay
what was the mistake some of it was
going to be worked at the campaigning
going out there like Hillary Clinton
just stopped campaigning Trump was doing
six rallies a day she's right those last
four days she did nothing she was out
there but but but that but Trump was
campaigning six rallies a day during
Biden and he wasn't doing any but it was
a different story there was a whole
different game we're not going to get
into that do you understand what I'm
saying with that part that was a you
know a a Black Swan event that took
place which is not something that's
consistent so I would take this golf
score and I would keep eliminating the
bottom 10. so we start off with 40
different things that we'd look at
statistics eliminate the bottom third
ten eliminate the bottom 20. eliminate
the bottom 30 then I got the top ten now
I want to see what is the most important
reason why somebody gets elected then I
take the top five then what I do from
the running RNC I go and I ask my guys
now this is a completely different job
I'm going to ask my recruiters to say I
want you to give me a list of 50 names
that meets these five criterias with a
score so run a golf score on a thousand
people that could be potential
presidents put Dave Rubin on that list
put Tucker Carlson on that list put you
know Ben Shapiro on Dallas put Charlie
Kirk on that list put all these guys on
that list and run a golf score
boom I'm gonna go talk to those 20 guys
schedule time with them to come and talk
to us they'll come and sit down and talk
to me I think you ought to consider
running for office you're out of your
mind I'll never do it totally get it can
I show you something what's that here's
the data I got here for you do you love
America I do how much do you love
America you okay if America becomes a
show no how much are you okay with
it are you a tolerant person are you
willing to fight for it I am I think you
need to run 2028. what are you talking
about Pat I think if you love America
you gotta run there's no way I'm going
to run you actually have a shot
you're one of the only 20 people in
America that has a shot
and my goal is to get the best top 20
formidable guys running for being a
president you're on that list I'm gonna
recruit so it's no longer who they
choose to run who we gotta recruit we're
just getting our options we're like ah
these are our best here we go
instead I'm gonna say no man by the way
I'm not taking anything away from Tim
spot Tim Scott I think he's a sweetheart
I'm not taking anything away from Nikki
Haley I thought she showed up to the
debate no I'm not taking anything away
from Ron or viveko what they're doing
but I believe we need to run it this way
then we go sell the right guys into
running I don't think that's happening
today
what do you do with the lies on both
sides related to all this because look I
supported Trump I've interviewed Trump I
like Trump in a lot of ways and I will
vote for him if he's running against the
Democrat so my cars are on the table the
lies about Florida the lies about covid
I I could go on and on the lies about
fauci and all that stuff like
what do you do with that you are someone
that cares about truth you've mentioned
your faith several times like what do
you do about that because I think a lot
of people are struggling with that right
now they're seeing the lies and they're
having trouble kind of connecting that
to the rest of their life or their ethos
and and I understand that okay
um here's what I've learned no matter
the more you study history and whether
you like this or not you can rip this
argument apart as much as you want some
of the best people that fought for our
freedom were complicated human beings
period misunderstood complicated complex
personalities weird upbringing difficult
to be around strange people weird habits
weird obsessions strange vices just
purely complex people who saved the
world these are very weird people
then you can look at the people that
were proper people the people you like
the people that all the things you and I
value that what a sweet man what is this
what are that they don't have the dog
fight I'm sorry history doesn't favor
Perfection the people that go out there
and are willing to do the fight they're
not going to fit the profile that
everybody is looking for is Donald Trump
one of the most complicated complex
strange people you support them one day
next day like what are you talking about
did she ask you a basic question do you
know the difference can a man be a woman
can a woman just say why are you taking
five seconds to answer the question just
say it and but you don't know why he's
doing that is he playing with her is he
playing with the audience did he just
have a meeting 30 minutes before making
Kelly with his five people that are
trying to figure out a way to give a new
messaging because he's losing three
percent of the vote in a you don't know
what he's thinking but what you do know
is everything he's doing is intentional
he doesn't wink he's not a Winger he is
a guy that will say wait you see what
we're gonna do wait till you see wait
till you see him wait to see it's kind
of like a salesperson wait do you see
wait do you see part of that is a
Visionary driver Future Truth totally
get that but he is also a guy that's
kind of watching everything and sizing
everything up and he's taking risk here
then he adjusts that message didn't work
let me change this or that message work
is pissing off the right people let me
poke on this guy but to me we're not
going to get who we're like aspiring to
get this perfect candidate it's just not
going to happen so since uh Trump has
chosen an awful lot of enemies I really
like what we've done with this shot can
we go to pbd's one shot one shot look at
that we get the book right in there
that's very nice choose your enemies
wisely who your enemies these days I got
a long list of them I got a long list of
them uh for me you know a part of it is
um you know what people are doing to the
greatest country in the world that
changed my life I'm going to do my part
with the fight against them the
establishment in a big way those that
are targeting kids to confuse kids I got
for them now it's a very formidable
opponent the people that are how much of
that is happening I mean you're here in
Florida I'm sure your kids are going to
grade schools and all that but is it is
it like just stuck in the culture that
that it even has to come up for your
kids who are obviously insulated I'm
still running an insurance company with
40 in 49 states and we got 46 000 agents
that 15 000 of them are active right now
so I get all the news from all these
different states on what's going on they
call me and I'm talking to them so we
have people on the ground that are
experiencing this in California and you
know Riverside then you got Oakbrook
Chicago then you got you know Dallas
even some schools in Dallas like wait
this has happened in some parts of
Dallas yes and you've got you know New
York or Calverton Maryland or you know
all these other areas they're going
through it right so you're hearing it so
I'm not okay with that part and then for
me I think in the media space I got a
lot of enemies in the media space and
you know some of these enemies are
making big mistakes some of them you're
just seeing that they're in it for only
money they haven't made money yet they
made a few million but they've not made
money money so they're kind of like
looking for their first 100 million or
first 200 million and I understand that
you've got to go through making that
first million then first 10 then first
100 and then maybe you go add the
additional zero and two additional zeros
then you have the ESG Community these
Larry Fink these Wall Street State guard
Vanguard Soros he's giving the fund back
to his son and he's running it now I
think his name is Alex 38 39 years old
and he's very close to Bill Gates
by the way good move for Gavin he's
going to need that guy's money and you
know this you know uh open Society
Foundation that Soros has given 32
billion dollars to the last 30 years or
so that that's a very powerful
non-profit organization open Society you
got to watch these guys so then you got
Hollywood and what they're doing so we
got to find a way to make movies to
compete against Hollywood and what they
got going on but there's a lot of
enemies but to me
you know you have to be you have to be
very intentional on choosing the right
enemies the wrong enemies bring out the
worst in you for example Let me Give an
example women
who chose the feminist movement they
chose The Wrong Enemy men are not the
enemy what are you doing how many 65
year olds today who are single with no
kids are coming out saying I made the
biggest mistake of my life what did they
do they chose The Wrong Enemy men were
never the enemy
Christians Muslims and Jews
they're choosing each other as the enemy
none of you guys know for a fact you've
not died and come back you've never met
Jesus or Abraham or Muhammad you pray to
it we all pray to it so what did the
enemies that we all see today
values and principles that are being
fought would you realize that Christians
are thinking Muslims are the enemy
Muslims are thinking Christians are
they're not the enemy it's the
establishment of globalists that are
pinning against each other we're
choosing the wrong enemy
we have completely most of us missed the
mark on choosing the wrong enemy and
it's destroyed people's lives
we've lost Decades of Our Lives some
years some Decades of some their entire
life is gone with so you know the reason
why I wrote this book was more for
people to realize
that we all make the mistake you know
sometimes you're like I'm gonna do it to
prove that guy wrong that guy doesn't
bring out the best in you but the other
guy does
but the other thing does or the other
institution does so for us we got enough
of the right enemies right now where the
driver what we wanted again God willing
if God keeps me around for 40 years oh
my God and we're healthy and what does
that get you feel like it's either 84.
84 yeah got the number for you I'll go
to 100 but it's a he dictates I'm going
to do my part I'm trying to take care of
my health right now the last few years
I've lost four inches on my waist
there's a few things I did four years
ago in July stopped drinking soda I
don't drink soda at all so
and then you know a few months ago I
don't eat breakfast except for Sundays
and breakfast my favorite meal I don't
do breakfast anymore I just skip
breakfast six days a week so I'm at a
weight where it's 235 238 is my weight
at my height I was at 258 260 which you
wouldn't tell if I'm 260 you know
because I'm a little bit taller so it's
kind of going to stretch but at 235 237
I'm good I have the right people around
me that my trying to take care of my
health and all that stuff but at the
same time look God can also say you
think too much of yourself man who do
you think you are man you do you think
we need you or you know you're going to
be okay come up here and have him go
clean the cloud who do you think you are
and I'm okay with that but how much is
that worry you though because I will
tell you this it's something that I've
been thinking about yeah like again I I
have the things that I want right now
and I've had a thought lately that I've
never had before which is I have like it
seems to me like this the shoe has to
drop at some point like if you have the
things that you want the life you're
living the life you're supposed to be
living like doesn't that doesn't last
for very long long right like something
always is going to happen whether you
know a death in the family whatever it
might be I've been thinking about my dad
dying since I was 18 years old when I
joined the army because my biggest goal
in life when I was six when my teacher
asked me what do you want to be when you
grow up I said I want to be a dad
because I wanted to be him he's a great
father very good father I wouldn't be
wine right now if it wasn't for him he
lives with me and I'm the happiest now
that he's in my house my kids see him my
dream was for my kids to me I met him I
met him I met him yeah I didn't realize
he was living there yeah my dream was
for my kids to know this Max I never met
his father right so I wanted I wanted
them to have an experience with this but
you know but I know I'm going to get a
phone call one day you know we're we're
going out to a nice uh my son's birthday
is coming up so we're going to the
Yankee Stadium it's going to be the
first time we're going as Yankees you
know we'll wrap with this yeah first
time we're going there so we're going to
go there and take him to the game and
then go to you know the the Jets game
Patriots game and all the stuff that
we're doing he can't go he just told me
yesterday I can't go I said what do you
mean you can't go right we're just
talking about this today he's trying to
convince me to convince my dad he said I
can't go he said if we go I'm not
feeling good he was in a hospital for
five days a couple weeks ago he's 81.
he's had 13 heart attacks he drank and
smoked for 35 years of it he smoked two
packs a day for 35 years you know 30
years until he had his heart text so the
fact that he's still here
Super Lucky of course I'm greedy I'd
love to see him go to 100 but have
perspective and you know I a long time
ago I realized when I would debate as an
atheist I was an atheist for 25 years
and then I eventually realized
hey pbd The Big Year Vision man the more
you need as much support as possible and
God's going to be your biggest support
when you're alone and nobody believes in
Your Vision you're going to need to talk
to somebody that's going to make sense
of this vision of yours you better get
close to the man upstairs so a lot of
things that I'm never going to have the
answer for
I have to rely on a source that's bigger
than me and that's the only thing I can
give my faith and comfort in I'm gonna
cry I'm gonna be in pain I'm going to be
emotional I'm going to have to go to a
lot of walks by myself and kind of break
down and go through it
but you know the grace that he's given
me man I'm you have no idea how big of a
role that the man upstairs plays in my
life so the reason why I'm saying this
is I fear those things are going to
happen but the way I know I'm going to
go through it is the One Source this is
the only way I can go through it only
way I can go through it we should
probably end there except you mentioned
the Yankee and you are now a minority
owner of the Yankees which when I saw
you tweet about that I was like that's
basically the coolest thing I've ever
heard lifelong Yankees fan I saw a Jeter
just a couple weeks ago in West Palm had
a great conversation with him the guy
well I saw that couldn't have been nicer
and I I June 26th is both of our
birthdays so for many of my birthdays I
used to go to Yankee Stadium on our
birthday and blah blah blah
um but you oh you're a minority owner of
the of the Yankees which uh I mean is
that just like as that's basically as
good as it is right so wait does that
mean you're in the owner are you in the
owner's boxer there's one owner's box
for all the guys that are the owners
yeah and that and you're just in it by
the way the steinburners owners box that
they've built it's up it's ridiculous
yeah you go to it yeah I mean when it
happened you know get a call from a guy
says hey I know you want to be an owner
of a team have you heard of the Yankees
and I'm like yeah two years ago he's
like I said yeah so what teams do you
have because I'm only interested in a
handful of teams and so I got you know
the Memphis Grizzlies I got this I said
yeah it's cool but no who are you
interested in I said well I would say
Yankees at the top and you know the
Lakers probably post LeBron but I would
say the Lakers will be second I'm not
interested in the Lakers today but those
are the two teams great
it's just not going to happen because
those things rarely open up well one of
the guys apparently was 80 81 years old
and he's at a phase where he's like he
wants to sell us shares and I get a call
you need to sign an NDA for what just
trust me you need to sign an MBA I
signed the India comes back and says
there's an opening I said you got to be
kidding me he says no but you got to go
through background check this thing's
going to take 12 13 months so then I
applied
interviewed with all the Yankees uh
folks then MLB did a background check on
us God knows how long that took then
eventually I'm like listen this thing's
done it's just not going to happen I'm
too loud they're not going to hire me
they're not going to allow me to come in
et cetera et cetera says well guess what
the Yankees uh owners want to meet you
in New York great I flew out to New York
I sat in a room Randy Levine you got
Tony here the CFO yge you got Noel here
the CEO has been with him since 1974
1964. and then halstein burn over here
I say you sure you guys are comfortable
with NASA because I'm not ESG I'm not
this I'm not that I'm not this
and you actually said that you you word
for word I told them everything I said
and I'm just getting started so you need
to understand you're going to be forced
to tell me to sell my shares and I'm
telling you I'm not going to be quiet
it's the only thing you guys got to know
is we don't care where you are totally
fine with us we're comfortable with that
but we have one rule
I saw was that rule he said how's the
boss
we don't want your opinion the only time
we want your opinion is if we ask for it
and I look it out and says I'm the boss
I said Hal you're the boss
so I left and we were in Bermuda
celebrating you know family you know we
go once a year yeah family vacation
summer time I get the call what are you
doing Pat I'm sitting down reading a
book congratulations you're officially a
minority under the Yankees I couldn't
freaking believe it bro I'm like are you
yeah yeah you got to keep the oh yeah
yeah you know of course and it's like
you know you're going to their wife the
kids all this stuff I'm like oh my God
my kid was watching the uh one of the
greatest documentaries of all time of uh
uh uh uh uh
one of the greatest uh who he won 10
World Series why am I forgetting his
name Yogi Berra Yogi Bear's document by
the one of the best documentaries of all
time ever good luck watching it without
breaking on crying yeah literally Yogi
Bear documentary so my son watches it
I'm seeing Dylan he's emotional I
watched the documentary then I get the
announcement then we're going to the
Yankees stadium and we're going to go
there and show them around and they're
going to get a tour the entire thing
it's a great experience but again it's a
dream right there's an element of I'm
44. but I want to I want to the people I
always liked and respected the most they
had an element of being childlike I
don't want to lose the ability of being
shall not childish child like that
childlike element is creative is
spontaneous as curious is in pursuit of
something you understand like I love
looking at my baseball cards and I've
become that 13 year old kid that was
dreaming about one day having a Mickey
Mantle car like oh my God what if one
day so this this brings me back to the
14 year old path he was just a kid I
said there's there's no way this is ever
going to happen your dad works at a 99
cent store so super grateful incredible
dream one of the items on a bucket list
but it was a great experience on that
note my friend you know how this thing
is going to end because I'm going to
bring out Young pbd
we're going to play horse on my
basketball court yeah I'm gonna lose in
your suit tell you in advance
but I look because I've seen you your
shots I know what you're doing okay
thanks oh man this was great appreciate
you for having me on yeah if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell